Bru's and major hotel chains are getting
a digital makeover voice recognition
technology allows guests more control
over everything from lighting to photos
on the wall but while may look and sound
exciting travel editor Peter Greenberg
shows us why you may need to pay more
attention to protecting your personal
information Peter good morning and good
morning for decades hotels have worked
hard to offer travelers a home away from
home but aside from now standard perks
like cable TV in room jacuzzis and let's
not forget those mini bars few things
have changed until now so this is the
workshop this is it this is where the
magic happens at Marriott headquarters
in Bethesda Maryland
researchers are working to replace hotel
rooms that once looked like this to
smart rooms that start off looking like
this with a few voice commands
blinds lights TV the room springs to
life what we've collected we start to
understand the preferences Adam Allen
mode is in charge of customer experience
now everything in this room is
essentially wired than if you wanted to
raise it lower the shades if I like an
ice box of room to go to sleep and I'm
not in the room the room knows through
its sensors that there's no one in here
guests could go on to their personal
profiles and add workout schedules
request weather updates and even upload
personal photos to have on display
before they walk in the door at least
one Marriott shower now uses smart glass
technology so guests can jot down their
thoughts on a fogged up mirror and then
have them emailed to their smartphones
the idea is that it's personalized to
the customers all that data including
your location and those voice commands
can be saved for future use this will
grow with interaction and collection of
more data and all these types of systems
are built with an intelligent engine
that actually learns through customer
interactions it gets that much better so
if you're a guest in your pro to talking
at yourself in the room you can get to
some serious trouble theoretically but
you have to ask the room with specific
commands does it happen yes when you
have these smart hotels they have a
token on your phone where they're
knowing where you go they know what type
of coffee you order they know what you
order in the restaurant
Eric Cole is a cyber security expert and
former security adviser to President
Obama the idea is now it can improve
customer serve
the problem is huge violation of
personal privacy this room is all about
the guest room of the future like
Marriott Hilton is also in on technical
revolution both chains now offer perks
like electronic keys so guests can open
hotel room doors and then we oh wow yeah
but it's a convenience call says needs
to be used with caution
he says the Bluetooth signal sent from
your smartphone might be unencrypted and
could be hacked from up to 15 feet away
somebody could go in and intercept your
key they could also track your locations
and if somebody can steal that digital
signature they can run up charges that
you would have to pay for before you
even check in you can put in all of your
preferences Alexandre Jarrod's is a
senior vice president at Hilton whose
new rooms can be controlled with a
smartphone app no the technology is gee
whiz and it's a WoW can't be hacked we
have worked and continued to work to
make sure that we're you know making
sure that that does not happen
and while the backend staff might be
working to make sure your hotel stay is
as pleasant as possible experts say
hotel guests need to be careful about
how much personal information they share
what most people don't realize is with
these smart hotels you are opting into
everything by default they are tracking
your location they can control every
aspect of your room think about what you
need and then opt out of everything else
now the option of using a regular room
key remains available as does opting out
of any of the smart room features now
both Hilton and Marriott say they have
security measures in place to protect
personal information adding that the
safety of their guests remains their top
priority but one other note about that
smart hotel shower wall yeah there you
dot your notes out on mm-hmm
beware the law of an unintended
consequences because especially when it
comes to the environment some of us
think a little bit slower than others in
the shower get ready for Marriott's
water bill okay I don't know about that
Digital key
I still cuz somebody could take the
digital key and you wake up and there's
somebody standing in your room I don't
like I like the idea that you can put
pictures up in the room and I could put
pictures of Peter Green everybody people
will like the voice commands because the
shades yes
those kinds of things especially
controlling the temperature of your room
before you get there that's okay that's
my club sandwich that's tacky bedspreads
Peter when those both came when those
those bedspreads came on both her and I
went look technology will help you there
remove the bedspread immediately yeah
thanks very much